so what happens next with Canada closing
its applications for temporary emergency
visas for ukrainians ihor Michael
tischen CEO of the Ukrainian Canadian
Congress joins us to explore the options
hi ihor
hello thanks for the invitation uh those
who might still seek Refuge what are
their options now
well we just saw a news release from the
government of Canada today we're looking
forward to some clarification in the
coming week because it's uh not entirely
clear what the the details will be but
we believe that there's still a pathway
for ukrainians to come to Canada albeit
with some reduced services
your opinion
opinion The Right Move
have so far but kind of introducing this
new one
well we have gotten assurances that the
the kuwit program the candid Ukraine
emergency assistance uh Visa will
continue uh to allow people who've
applied for that program to arrive in
Canada up until March of 2024. uh that
was an announcement the government made
earlier this year and we've rece
received assurances that that will
continue and those people uh there's
about a million applicants through that
program about 200 000 of which have
arrived so they those are the people who
are staying in hotels temporarily with
some uh services and one-time Income
Support so there's a variety of of
programs happening at the same time that
we need to just get some clarity from
the government on exact details and
operational status hopefully we get that
Clarity sooner rather than later uh but
for the ukrainians who already have
arrived or are set to arrive what
resources are available to them to help
with their transition
so for people who are arriving now under
this cuet emergency Visa they're
entitled to 14 days uh at a hotel uh
which helps them get oriented in Canada
with some services on you know setting
up a social insurance number Healthcare
banking uh really orientation to life in
Canada uh we have community volunteers
who are helping meet people at airports
and as well help with additional needs
in terms of integrating into communities
there is a one-time financial payment
that is helping people
who've arrived with their first
apartment or or with emergency kind of
food needs for their couple weeks in
Canada just as they've arrived before
they find a job so it's really a lot for
people to arrive you know into a country
where they have never been to find a job
find a place to live and to adjust and
so it's there's a lot uh there's a lot
of support both you know from a
community volunteer perspective but also
some services
has the program been a success so far
what are you hearing from them about
their transition
it's hard to sort of use the word
success in this context because these
are people fleeing a war we're in day
507 of the Russian full-scale Russian
invasion of Ukraine so um you know all
of this is happening in a circumstance
where we wish people wouldn't have to
flee their homes and wouldn't uh
wouldn't need to become refugees so
success I think can be in the sense of
uh we've seen Canadians you know from
all communities Coast to Coast to coasts
welcoming uh ukrainians uh helping them
you know at every step of the way we've
seen provincial and Municipal
governments you know create new programs
to help them on a temporary basis and
we're seeing the federal government
continue to make some moves to allow
people in
um and unfortunately you know the longer
the war goes the more people will be
needing this kind of assistance we do uh
want a scenario where the war ends and
where peace returns and people have
options for rebuilding their lives
said ihor will leave it there for today
thanks so much for joining us
thank you very much